watch me please
Lamar Jackson talking about his meeting
last night with Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers great advice from Aaron
Rodgers Lamar Jackson get down avoid
those hits he's gonna be running the
ball we saw him run the ball last night
big cat he didn't run at week one in the
preseason last night he ran the ball
twice for 14 yards that count he had a
nice 18 yard touchdown run that was
called back for a penalty 6 for 10 throw
on the ball for 58 yards we still
haven't seen the real Baltimore offense
it's like this great mystery of what's
hiding under that sheet and they're
trying to keep it covered up as long as
they can but we know Lamar Jackson can
play well he played very well last year
when he was thrust into the mix if he
can complement the running that he saw
that he showed us last year with the
passing that we saw at Louisville this
guy can be a great quarterback I
I'll stop you right there the passing we
saw at Louisville I mean we saw in
accurate passing at times and it's all
about that that's really all I care
about with Lamar Jackson the running is
fantastic he's a phenom when it comes to
that but if you can't throw the ball and
you can't make the defense respect the
fact that you can hit guys in tight
windows and all this is irrelevant I'm
not saying that Lamar can't do that but
we didn't see it you know week in and
week out last year when they had that
run so that's that's it for me it's just
ke can he make all the throws and if he
can and I think he can then he will be a
next level quarterback but to say you
know he's good he's gonna throw like he
did in Louisville there were some
inaccuracy Louisville on he had but he
had he had something but he had some
incredible production at Louisville
that's what I'm talking about he was
right he was actually better the year
after he won the Heisman but the team
wasn't good enough to get him on the
Heisman radar he had great production
running and throwing at Louisville and
those windows you're at the windows are
order at the college level I remember
with deshaun Watson there was a concern
that he had too many turnovers too many
mistakes but when the window got tighter
he got more accurate that and that's the
challenge can Lamar Jackson find a way
to become more accurate as he grows into
this position and we saw it last year
when they beat the Chargers on that
fantastic game they played in LA late in
the season and the Chargers come all the
way to Baltimore for the playoffs have
figured out how their offense works and
we're able to beat them will that be you
know with everything's under wraps and
we don't know what's going to look like
but will it be a situation where if you
have tape on the Marge axon he might not
have all the dimensions that a
quarterback needs in the NFL because
that's really what it is Lamar Jackson
and I think you'll get there
but you have to be able to do everything
to keep defenses honest because if you
can't do if you can't make some of the
throws that NFL quarterbacks need to
make and make them accurately a defense
can can game plan pretty easily for you
and shut that down so it's gonna be
exciting to see the Marv Jackson is one
of those guys that like I enjoy watching
him and I can't wait to see his
progression but these first few weeks
the Ravens a team that should be very
good especially on the defensive side
it's going to be very fascinating to
watch at Louisville went from 54.7%
completion percentage 256 to 259 1 never
at 60% you got to be 60 or better at the
NFL level to be regarded as an accurate
passer so that's where that's one big
area where he needs to improve and I
always call him college football plays
as a gamble I call them college football
players when you need Andover or you
need something to happen there's always
in college football two or three plays
where it looks like the safety has just
nuttin isn't even on the field didn't
even check in where there will just be
no secondary out there so you aren't
going to get those in the NFL you aren't
going to get those 70-yard everything
just fell apart and no one's standing in
the middle of the field and will he be
able to adjust to that and find those
tight windows one guy who has shown that
he has found the tight windows so far
Sam Donald the Jets quarterback he was
so much better last year after he came
back from an injury and there was a vibe
late in the season that maybe this guy
can be special I'll tell you
last night big cat I saw a couple throws
from Sam Darnell that made me think holy
crap this guy's on the verge of doing
something great for the Jets squeezing
it into spots like that one there if
you're watching on NBCSN finding the the
you know in stride get the ball where it
needs to be and you complement him with
Le'Veon Bell who probably won't play at
all this preseason but he is looking
great at practice he's looking like the
old lady on bail
you put those two guys together and yeah
and you know my position all along has
been between the bills and the Jets one
of those two teams is gonna put
themselves in position to contend for a
playoff spot and they meet week one and
I think both of those guys Josh Allen
and Sam Donald are ready to step up and
there could be some memorable games that
you're involving both of those teams I
like where Donald is and I like where
he's heading yeah I watched a little of
this game last night as well
Sam darn old youngest quarterback to
ever start an NFL game last year had an
injured wide receiver Court an injured
wide receiver running backs he played
the third toughest defenses he now has
Adam GaSe I think that all kind of comes
back you know in the arrows pointing up
for him what I also was impressed with
Mike I don't know if how much of this
game you watch the Jets defensive line
is going to be very good and I think
their defense is going to be very good
and they might be just the new color
scheme but they looked fast they look
really fast
I agree with you I think the Jets will
be one of those teams that will be
knocking on that playoffs whether it be
a wild card or maybe you know get to
that 9 10 wins where they're making it a
little bit nervous for the Patriots but
I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna fall
in the trap that everyone falls into
right around this time every single year
where they declare me other no in the AL
East nope no no no it's nope you know
that sports media does every single year
they're like well watch out for the
Dolphins this is the year nope and then
till Tom Brady retires you cannot say
that yeah I agree with you on that I
think the best they can hope for the
Jets were the bills or even the Dolphins
is a shot at the fives here to the 16
for the Dolphins that is a real stretch
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports